I'm having some trouble getting my list together.
I've got about six or seven businesses,
a few from Google Ads, HomeAdvisor, and Thumbtack.
That enough?
Yeah, Kenny, it takes one.
It takes one.
I think a lot of times you think because you've
worked the call center or you've seen some of these movies,
you think you need like this couple hundred list.
No, some of my lists are five people.
Some of my lists are five people, but I know their name,
I know their company, I know all the details about them,
I know where they're ranked on Google,
and I call and I'm snipering instead of doing the shotgun approach.
Yeah, six and seven could be great.
Okay. You might go through the six or seven and nothing hits.
I wouldn't tell you to give up on that.
I wouldn't tell you to give up on that city.
I would tell you if you go through all those people
and you've literally they're just not interested,
pause everything and then go and do another campaign,
do another deal, get a deal,
come back with a fresher set eyes and some momentum and you'll have a different result.
Okay. Yeah, that is enough.